Say anything bad because I'm lying
Okay, okay, okay
I'm lying
Did my stream
Is it going up or still working?
I don't know
Still?
Okay
Yeah, it takes like a hot second for me to even appear like when I guys guys guys
It killed my broadcast room
You want?
You killed your broadcast room right now like it suddenly like stop streaming and then my my power wash simulator
Okay, I replay deleted
I'm live right now so don't say anything
I'm live right now
This is a nightmare
Chat, we're so sorry
Oh god
We're so professional
It's been awful
Reflects you don't know
How many of them were...
Merci, will I make you a new room?
Yay
Hold on
Okay
I'll go make myself some tea while we're here
No
Hey, look at that, look at that
Wait, what are you doing?
No, you're a li-
Okay, you can go make some tea
We'll keep-
No, we'll just-
You've got this stream
I don't know how to make some tea
You can go make tea, that's fine
We need to help Merci
Yeah, stream up
Guys, we have been at this for 26 minutes
We were on power washer for one hour
And every time we went past four of the girls connecting
The connection started timing out for some reason
But if for some reason in power washer
If you haven't played the entire campaign
It doesn't allow you to have six persons in your lobby
And I'm the only one with a finished save file
And it was too late to ship all the code information
To send it on your stream
So, basically, Shibi was like
I'll set this one out, you guys just do it
And we're like, no, we can't do it
The whole point of this is that we're all together in this
So then we're like, right, who's got Gmod, right?
I don't have it, right?
Who's got RAF, right?
Who's got this game?
I don't have it
I was trying my best
Shibi was like going through the list
She was flicking them pages like next page, next page, next page
Jackbox, okay, that won't work
Gartik, okay, sure
All right, we'll do Jackbox
And then, wait, that requires us to screen record discord
I'm like, we can't have that
We see outrageous things in the discord
We don't even have a HR department, so we can't share
So then Gartik Phone, which I've never played before
is coming in clutch right now
Amy's currently making a cup of tea
Mercy is just getting a room set up for her
because she accidentally nuked her vod of the collab stream
It was an hour split
This couldn't have gone any worse
I think that's pretty on character for us
Yeah, if someone can insert that meme and put all of her hairs on it
and be like, aren't v-tubers cute when they're almost...
That's all I'm gonna say
Well, you guys can finish the sentence after that
I can?
No, I'm kidding
No, no, you're not like that
The refunds, the snowberries, the billion hearts
The harem, I remember
I was like, okay, I'm gonna be honest
When the harem told me they were called harem
I read it as harem, and I was like, that makes no sense
for Shibi's character design
I do too, I do too
I was like, what?
I have a harem of so many people
that are my little, you know, playthings and clients
and they're my harem, and that's hair
which is a rabbit
but it's not a rabbit, hair and rabbit are different
but you know what I mean
It's a good pun
It's a pun, exactly
And they're also called harlots
The individuals are harlots, or harlots
Wait, hold on
I thought you said hairless
Wait, let me...
They're hairless
Some of them aren't, I can tell you that
Do you still have that thumbnail, Mercy?
Are we good now?
I got a tooth
Almost, almost to me
Mercy, if you still have that thumbnail
if you just throw up the stream
Is she gonna throw up on stream?
Stream is what you're screaming
Yeah, it should default to that
If you just change to the thumbnail and pick our take
I'm chilling, telling herself to stream
What are you screaming?
I'm dying, I cannot right now
Oh, my goodness gracious
Yeah, how's the volume?
Yeah, it's my volume, okay
Can you hear everyone else?
Miro
Who said the harlots are waxed in my chat?
The harlots are waxed
I need them to be clean and proper
I see it, I see it, hold on
Okay, that's good
How do I change the garlic phone?
On Manage Broadcast on OBS
And it was not doing so bad
Oh, they called, we have the column
Pichinko, thank you for the 10 members
My 10 gifted
Don't gift right now
This is awful
Any gifters?
At 2 o'clock
Yeah, any gifters for my non-monetized channel?
Oh, no!
How can this happen to me?
I was muted the entire time!
I can hear you
We heard you
No, what is happening?
Right, mercy
What is this?
This is awful
This is a fever dream, guys
This isn't real
We're all in beds
I guess I should change my stuff now
Why do we need to change?
No, you don't have to change anything
As long as the game is on stream, you can change it after stream
No one gives a shit when the stream is called
As long as we're online right now
I'm just doing it because there's like
I'm sitting here
The girls are running around
Like everything's on fire
And I'm like, it'll be fine
We're good
We're gonna play some Gartik phone
We're gonna have a great time
They think the world is gonna end
Don't forget to like and subscribe on this stream
If you're enjoying your experience as a viewer
Smash that bell to get notifications of when we go live
Smash that bell to get smashed
Oh, I see
Yeah, like with alcohol or something
Yeah
Not literally
I can't help myself
She loves smashing
Like Nigel Thornberry
She just says smashing
And that's it, you know
She just loves, I see love smashing
Are we here?
No
I'm barely here right now
Okay, finally
We're here
I'm sorry for the mess
We're good
Yeah, we're here
She's talking to her chat
We, a viewer, have done the holistic approach
Where none of us will mute
So
You're just gonna hear everything
All at once
That's all
We're all
It just is a remainder
All donations, my memberships
Or super chats will be addressed
At the end of the stream
When it's not an absolute cluster
Buck of all six of us together
But yes
The whole premise of the Power Washer
Was I was gonna do a gag and be like
Oh, Viola isn't doing so well
We might go bust
So everyone put a bikini on
And get cleanin'
Well, that idea is out the window now
So instead we're playing Gartik Phone
I've never played it personally
She be
Suggested it and I
Her word is LOL
So let's just take it away
I am taking over the company
I am the shadow CEO
Yes
Okay, do you guys want to start?
You ready?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
Woo!
Let's do it, let's do it
Three, two, one
We can finally do it
Let's go!
I know cheating
The guy is so chat
Don't fucking cheat
Don't fucking do it
I swear it out, beat your ass
Shhh
I don't know
How long do I have to do the sentence?
Help me out, help me out
Reflings don't give out way until it's over
This is our secret
Oh wait
How many
Wait, I don't think they'll know what that is
So let me change it
Hello?
Oh we don't have any time
What's wrong?
What the
Alright
We have to draw these now
Oh my god.
I'm driving with a...
After the mouse.
You broke the...
I can't see.
Don't cheat.
This is so bad.
Oh no.
Oh.
I've never done this before.
Wait, can I make my pain smaller?
Is she...
Oh no.
Why is he getting drunk?
Why am I drunk?
I don't even know what's happening.
Why are you guys screaming?
Oh my god.
Holy fuck.
How much time is left in my god?
The top right corner is the indicator.
Not the sharing.
I'm an artist.
Wait, what is this?
I brought my drawing tablet out.
An artist.
Oh my god.
I'm an artist.
Oh yeah, wait.
All you can fucking draw about me.
You're all done.
I have to look up at the logo.
We need to witness them.
Hold on.
What the fuck am I doing?
What is this?
I should whip out my drawing tablet for this.
Actually, it's better with a mouse.
It's better with a mouse.
How much time?
No, it's better with a mouse if it looks like...
It looks great.
This looks like a fucking...
Okay, the top.
He's just gonna do something else.
I'm done.
What does text say?
I can't tell you.
These are items.
That's all I'm saying.
100% wood.
Why not?
These are the chat logs.
We need to put the chat logs in quick.
Good answer.
You guys aren't ready for mine?
Let's put that in detail.
We need some wood detail.
Americans always look in detail.
What is this?
What the fuck?
Oh shit, what's the name?
There we go.
There you go.
What do you think?
Tilly! Tilly!
My gen mates are wild!
I don't know what he looks like.
Look at this Google picture.
God.
She be sent so far away.
I'm away from my wife.
Oh right.
I don't know what Thornberry looks like.
Oh no.
I had to look it up.
I'm just guessing.
I'm just going for it.
What do I look like?
I look like this.
I don't look like that.
Sugar.
Don't question.
And then I got my planters.
Bunches.
Walk it.
That's me.
That's the story I've ever made.
How do you draw?
I don't know.
Perfect.
I don't know how to draw.
I don't know how to draw anymore.
That's pretty good right?
I think I agree.
They agree with me.
I don't know.
Hold on.
I need to add some.
Ginger in it.
There you go.
That's me.
I don't know what.
That adds some hair.
What?
This is awful.
I'm sorry.
This is...
I don't know.
Let's draw some hair.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Oh my goodness.
Draw his thorn.
His nose.
Just google a picture.
Don't do that.
I still ate the thorn run.
That is very nice.
Thank you.
My little reeflings are saying I'm a true artist.
Wait, wait. No.
Emi's hair is not orange.
Emi's ginger.
I'm ginger?
You thought you were blonde?
Your hair is orange.
I thought I was blonde.
No.
What the fuck am I looking at?
I'm sorry.
That's my image.
What does that even say?
My wash.
Me-i-ow.
Oh, meow.
Oh my god.
Meow.
Which one of you speaks Spanish?
That's French.
Oh lord.
What?
Oh, how am I supposed to draw that?
Jesus Christ.
Did we even have...
What do I look like?
Oh wait, I can't even draw the fucking toilet.
Alright, hold on.
What do I even look like?
This is terrible.
I'm out.
This is so hard with the mouth.
Wait, this is not feet.
This is armpits.
We're like, we're grabbing onto the ground for dear life in this one.
Right, armpits.
So...
I don't know.
I like throwing in words that they don't know.
Because none of you guys know like some English phrases.
Or some like jokie phrases.
So I can already...
What I'm hearing is that a lot of you guys are misinterpreting what I've written.
And it's very funny.
It's going all over his back.
It's not looking good.
How do you draw an angry mouth?
Oh, there we go.
And then...
Armpits!
We need to draw...
This is amazing.
What does the Walmart logo mean?
Your armpits has become sentience.
Walmart.
I'm not even going to explain to Mercy.
I'm not even going to...
Oh wait, don't your toilets have like...
Oh wait!
I don't know what's wrong with him.
I don't know.
It just makes it better.
It makes it worse.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
Uh...
He's just like...
This is too fucking funny.
Perfect.
I think that works out.
There we go.
The radiation.
I can't wait to see everyone.
All according to plan.
Now we'll get to see everything.
I'll do manual.
There's going to be no voiceover.
And then we'll do beginning from the end.
Okay.
So...
So I said,
I see with Nigel Thornberry's face
saying smashing.
I mean...
And Mercy too.
I'm very old.
Smash weak.
I'm strong.
Oh my god!
I love it.
Why does she look like...
Oh my gosh, she looked like that!
Okay, Imi, go ahead.
Oh no.
Oh boy.
You're honest, you wanted it.
And then there's Chris Hansen.
And I said, oh, she said it's going to jail for the crime scene on date.
Oh no!
Oh shit, I'm going to jail.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, full circle!
I love it, I love it!
That actually worked out.
Why does your OG Santa such a fat cock?
Jesus fuck.
Because he loves me and he's dead gross sick.
It grew six times that day.
All right.
Sestrani's.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
Merse, it's cheesy, fester and fat.
I feel like her feet is actual cheese.
I know.
Hey, I like that pull.
And I wrote stinky peats, which is his feet, but little slang.
And then she drew pits.
Oh my god, that's too good.
Is she cutting out?
She's screaming so loud.
Azura.
Azura!
I see, very good artist.
I got it from fucking AC.
Thank you.
What does that even mean?
When your job is a poo, so when your poo hits your prostate on the way out.
Oh, a job is a poo?
What is this?
Is he me sucking?
Have you suckered on them hot too?
Oh wait, has she given a blowjob?
That's what it looks like.
That's what it looks like to me.
Oh my god.
The drill.
The drill is so good.
Oh boy.
Over some pie.
Oh my god, that's pretty good.
That's cute, I love that.
That's a really cute toy.
How is that a cat?
Meow.
Meow winky face guys, come on.
Okay, it's a winky face.
I was like, what is meow us?
I was like, who is this Spanish?
Niko with.
We are so good.
That's good, that's good.
I love that.
Okay, this makes sense.
This makes sense of what on earth we were drawing.
See, that's the checkout and like that's items on the shelves.
I worked really hard.
Oh my god.
Oh this is a good diaper.
I see understood me.
Why is he praying?
Oh my god, praying for the den full.
I love the details.
Taking a mind to shots.
Honestly.
Why is it coming out of his back?
It was good everywhere.
It's like on his back.
Yeah, I can't.
Toilet stall gap.
Because that's all I see about when I like see American memes.
They're like, oh the toilet stall.
The toilet gap is so big.
You can literally look at people's eyes through it.
Do you guys want to play a different version?
Oh no, we have them closed because you know it's a private time
and you're very vulnerable taking a big job.
So yeah, it's actually closed everywhere else in the planet.
Oh you're so lucky.
I had people peeking at me in high school through the stalls
and I'm like, can I help you?
Me too.
Oh no, is there a DC?
Is there a check?
Is there a DC check?
Are you in the lobby? Do you need to reload the lobby?
It's gonna do it on its own usually.
No, I'm gone.
The link should be in the discord.
Don't show your fucking screen on the discord.
They'll see everything.
They'll see all of our naughty photos we just sent to each other.
It's mostly memes.
Any memers?
I mean, to be fair, we did share...
We did share some ugly memes.
We did share some smoky nudes of ours.
They've seen my titties.
I started roleplaying as the girls with my nudes.
I was like, this is what Evie would do.
This is what Acey would do.
Discord is so chaotic.
Okay, real though.
But also, I did snort out my tea.
It like went down the wrong hole and went out my nose.
Wow, Marcy out here snorting tea.
Gotta lay off, that's a stosteroad.
It hurts so much.
Yeah.
Are you in game?
She's like so in my ears.
My cliz getting another heartbeat right now every time she talks.
I have a turn with her eye around this.
I love her landing.
And my fingers turned out like that.
Oopsie.
I don't know.
I feel like Azura could do a really good Jennifer Coolidge impression.
Jennifer Coolidge.
I don't know Jennifer Coolidge's impression.
She was like, wait, you don't know Jennifer Coolidge.
Jennifer Coolidge.
I have such big titties.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Jennifer Coolidge.
Speaking of your chat for the Rizzler.
That's so good.
Why are we opening our got for the Rizzler?
Drop the bass, plow, plow.
Azura, click that link in the general discord to ring the bell.
Is it not letting you back in?
Have you been reading more?
All I hear is screaming.
Your make cuts out with your eyes, Azura.
So it just goes.
What's happening?
It's constantly loading.
It's literally, let me do another invite.
Wait, if I, when you guys see the discord, if I open it up,
okay, you guys can't see it.
Perfect.
No, if you do, if you do capture.
I shouldn't see anything else.
I would close the window capture in the, in the OBS just in case.
Yes, you're going to turn off.
Are we restarting a new lobby?
A new lobby?
I think you're still inviting us lobby.
A bit of all.
Are we, are we going to another room?
I don't know.
I only see one of you.
No, on mine.
Sorry.
She's in, she's in.
Okay, which one should we play?
So you got normal, which we just did.
Knock off, keep yourself focused, try to replicate the drawings
while the clock gets faster.
Animation, create an animations in a collaborative way.
Icebreaker, play with a sentence, ask questions and have fun with other drawings.
Exquisite co-ops, create surrealist characters connected by the top of the drawings.
Don't know what that means.
Hold on.
I have one.
Burp friends, have a good time with that.
Compliment, complete the sketch.
Start with basic lines and see other players' interpretations.
Masterpiece, create a piece of art, play in a single turn with no time limit.
I feel like story would be funny, right?
A narrative using only the previous sentence as a reference.
Yes, okay, okay, story, story, story.
You want to do story?
Yeah, let's try story.
Wait, do I have to write a full story or just a sentence?
Just a sentence.
Just one sentence.
Okay, okay.
Do you like write the whole story or no?
No, you have really limited characters.
I don't know it.
No!
What did you do?
There's time, there's time.
Yeah, I got 15 seconds, love.
Oh my god, I wanted to write more.
You can only write one sentence.
I feel like I should be drunk.
What is this?
We are not beating the caca allegations with this.
No, we're not.
What the fuck is happening?
Oh, they're going to know this is me spelling it because I didn't use a Z on that.
I'm just going to leave it like that.
Yep, I'm sending it.
I'm not even spell checking.
Lack of spell check is good.
Fuck it.
Five seconds.
Fuck it, I'm bad at stories.
What is this?
It's mine!
Oh, the sentence is so small.
I want to give a bit more.
I think it gets shorter over time.
I want to feel it vibing.
I couldn't write until, fuck.
What?
What's that?
Let's see.
Oh no, what the fuck?
Fuck, I'm so bad at this.
Her name.
It's funny because...
Oh, I hate this.
I can't think of any names.
The Reeflings, the Snowberries, the Snickers,
the Pin Pals,
the Blean Harps, and the Herum.
I'll get to see this unfold.
And we're all just taping like...
Fuck it, I don't fuck around.
Wait, is that the fucking...
And...
You watch fucking...
Big Bang Theory?
Wait, that's a nice spell.
Paris.
Fuck!
Give me more!
WolfQuest reference, though.
I need more letters.
I need more like...
Amazing!
What?
Ten minutes pen song lyrics!
They jerk so hard, motherfuckers want to find me!
That sounds like Stevie!
No!
They jerk so hard, motherfuckers want to find me!
Wait, I don't know these lyrics.
This...
This agency...
We can't just...
I spelled it wrong, but that's the point.
I hate that they don't give you enough to write.
It's like...
Not enough.
Fuck off.
Oh boy, okay, let's see what's happening.
I'll do the auto.
So how about everybody reads their own story, like whoever did the first line.
Okay, cool.
Okay.
Oh, okay, I go first.
They also wanted some of the juicy.
Ew, cooties, you're not good.
Why do we both start the same?
There was a polar bear princess who was trying to fit in too.
Oh.
My love was stronger than any four in addition.
They couldn't stop jerking my love for jerk.
My jerk still hid my love for jerk.
I didn't know I had finished it.
I was like, this agency is crazy.
Ding ding.
Ding ding, that was supposed to be the song, like ding ding.
Ding ding, ding ding, ding ding.
Ding ding ding.
That was so hard.
Strawny, who was in Paris?
There was a beach of agency that was lit.
They all couldn't control their urges.
So they danced the pee-pee dance until they could.
And then finally, they peed everywhere on the floor,
the walls, the bed, the kite.
We're all filled with piss everywhere, but he loved it.
The fact that he was not even a piss prompt before AC came out with that.
AC couldn't hold it.
AC put him back to piss.
I'm dying.
This is so good.
Once upon a time, there were whores.
They were the elitists of whores.
They had a wild west.
They all had really cute cowgirl.
Pussycat, so cute.
So fuzzy.
Pussywarm.
Big bang theory, more like bang bang your mom last time.
You keep my mom out of your damn mouth.
He's turning to an argument.
That's the story.
That's the time they were like...
She's choking.
Oh no.
I'll save this time.
I can't.
I'm turning from shit to cum.
Oh, my face hurts from laughing.
This is so bad.
And now you guys know why I rate the scripts.
Why am I?
I got me in a zero row to buddy each other.
She was sad because she realized she didn't have a prostate.
Why do I keep talking about shit all of that?
Oh, great.
She became so bad.
I hate this.
Fuck no.
No.
I didn't want to be pregnant by Sonic.
Azura.
Azura, do you have a mic filter on?
I can never hear you.
Turn that mic.
Get that steel-
See that steel series.
Oh, fuck.
If I fart, I'll get everybody's stream.
You can't.
I deafened so you guys couldn't hear it on all five channels.
What is happening?
Can't wait for the vote if they survive.
Yeah, these votes.
They'll be fine.
Don't worry about it.
You guys want to play this one?
Or do you want to try another one?
Another, another, another.
New one, new one, new one.
Start with an incomplete drawing each turn.
Please, please.
No more shit.
No more shit in piss.
No.
No promises.
Each one.
I didn't even do any shit in piss stuff.
It was you guys.
Each turn is called compliment.
Compliment.
All the actions are a mystery.
Drawings and sentences are hidden during the game.
You can't hear Mercy.
Mercy test.
Mercy test?
Sorry.
I was muting because I was coughing because I was slapping my side.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Mercy test complete.
Do you want to do compliment?
What is that?
Complete the sketch.
We draw on each other's drawings, basically.
I wish I could do that.
Sure.
I think that would do it.
Yeah.
Can't wait to draw so much piss and shit.
Oh, God.
That's some basic lines.
Okay.
I'll do some basic lines.
I'll do this.
Maybe I could just...
Maybe I'll do some basic lines.
Okay.
All right.
Now I'm just going to draw a bunch of dicks.
I like it.
I'll leave it like that.
Castle.
No!
Are you joking?
What's that?
What happened?
You know exactly what you did.
And no, I don't have the strength to resist.
What?
Wait, I got it.
I got it.
I can make this.
I can salvage this.
This is the back legs of it.
And then this is its huge milkers.
And then this is its legs.
There you go.
Only a few more left.
Yeah.
You're so dirty.
Reflins.
Don't be so dirty minded.
Honestly.
Reflins.
I'll get the girls to tell you off if you don't behave.
That's shocking.
You guys don't have innocent eyes anymore.
Cute.
Rude me.
Wait, quiet is working hard.
Wait, am I supposed to finish this off?
Are we supposed to finish it off?
I think so because it's given us tons of time.
Hold on.
Oh, okay.
I fixed it.
A big fish up bra.
Oh my god, I've just made shimmy.
What the hell?
My name.
Oh wait, that's a thing.
Oh no, that looks like...
Dang it.
Let's just do the pencil.
Here we go.
I saved it.
Baby, give you a lot more time for the second one.
Yeah, you're to finish it.
You're to finish it.
Ah, you need to finish it.
Okay, I'm fucking stupid.
Never mind.
Okay.
So am I.
Don't worry.
I saved it.
Lemo girl.
I can't write.
Hell.
Let's put some nice shading in.
To make this look extra beautiful.
Wow.
Let's put lipstick on.
Yeah.
So beautiful.
I saved it.
They prank him.
I think this is the best I know.
Maybe a bit of fluff on Matteo.
Oh, wait.
Who drew a pair of hairy ball sacks?
What?
You're supposed to add the shaft.
I really know what I want to do,
but I know I shouldn't do it because we're on YouTube.
I'm fixing this.
Oh, no.
I can't think of one thing.
This is amazing.
Oh, wait.
Maybe hold on.
Hold on.
I got it.
Fuck.
How do I go back?
Okay.
Fuck.
What is this?
They've got a big head.
Look at it.
Oh, I've drawn them too.
Let's practice.
This is so fucking good.
Let's fucking go.
I'm trying so hard right now.
I can't even think of anything to say.
Oh, my gosh.
Use your imagination.
I can't even think of anything to say.
There you go.
Thank you, all.
I'm so proud of you.
I'm like...
We need to be nice to the earth people.
Your laugh is so cute.
Thank you.
I think I did my really well, yeah, it's a water bottle
I saved the pair of all sex
Did you make it into a dog
Just work. I don't know
Can you do better shut the fuck up? I
Love when you do that
You're asking me not to draw a vagina with this
How do I make this how do I save this
Okay, I won't draw that because that would be
Oh my god, I just realized all this instead
Merci snippets like fucking girl goo from star wars
Oh, wait, no, is it heartbreak on the chair?
You thought women were less immature than men you're wrong
I wasn't gonna draw a coochie or a woman giving birth, but I'm not gonna I'm resorting to this instead
I've literally don't know what the fuck I'm doing right now. There we go. Wait, hold on. I don't know
Oh my god, I have time
Did you guess who it is now
Um, and then be light ones pin pals
Pin pals quick quick quick quick
Oh my god, this is okay, and then we'll kind of
These are light ones
I'm trying I'm trying I'm trying I got it
Oh god refunds refunds, how could I forget you're fucking
I saved it I saved it
This is the best I got I ain't gonna
This is a really specific reference and I don't know anyone can I get it but
There used to be a
Flash game where your guy was on like a snowboard. I love that game. Yes. I want you to literally just drawn that
I literally this is perfect
That's it, that's my drawing
Someone says lane raider. Oh, I thought we're just called
Re
What is bear pantsu?
Not away all of like people were asking me to draw a bear wearing underwear. I was like, what the fuck is wrong with you guys?
Pants yeah, I remember fancy pants
Because he had big old pants that were fancy
Raina and now is not the time to hope you know the story was he blundered it on me though
You know the story
I might make that up
I
Right hydration check girlies, I don't want you to die in okay, you know the story
Pants reasons
He's gargling my balls. Sorry. He had no hair color, but it's pants for yellow
Let me do that. Do you have a beard? I don't know. I drew something
Yeah
Needs hip. Oh, yeah, you're right. I don't really know how to do that though
Can I zoom in?
So good beer braid braid is pants
No, fuck I didn't mean to add that what is this who drew ball sacks everywhere
Hahaha, it's not you she be I only know I didn't draw a full sack
Only oh I got it
Who's whispering? I
It's definitely a zero
There is whispering some like evil incantations to us
I
See it's great. That's not nice. Hold on. This is all I see right now, and I'm not even gonna pretend
It was definitely a zero that drew the ball sack 100%
Why does like why do I feel like this is a lie?
No, I didn't draw it. I'm really drawing over it right now
If you guys didn't know a zero's ears. I actually have golden little jewelry on the end of them
Oh, this is ice. She's pimped out with jewelry, but it's like not a vanity thing. You go
for her first
bike ride
All right, isn't cheating to erase all fuck it is. Isn't it cute?
All right, so if you didn't know when a woman
When a woman lactates to a hammer
Oh my god, it goes through the fabric
Okay, so they'll be sand is so happy for her
I know this isn't as there is
Oh, it's terrible. Get rid of that
Oh my god, you can't just control it with my life
Now I want to start talking about lactation, duh
This is yeah, it was right before she sat in chocolate. That was correct milk
What the fuck milk
The best I go
That's the cyber
I thought you were drawing a cute bunny face and now them some titties me
It's all I can see
I have saved I have single-handedly saved the stream probably
This is supposed to be it the liquid
the liquid
Oh, I have to draw my own drawing
I don't even know what to draw for my own drawing
I'm fine. I started it and I'm gonna finish it. It's me
I'm looking fucking mental
I don't know
I'm already pooped from this
A little blip
It's the odd it's the old Mac, okay
Okay
I would talk but it takes too much brain power to
Yeah
What my cats are fighting stop
This is a net
Yeah
It's a pretty good net
I think I did a great job
Uh right hold on
How do you spell squelch?
Squelch?
Yeah
Yeah, yeah
Is it the amazon?
Oh my god
Is it the reverse amazon position when the what are you drawing?
Yeah, like that's that's definitely what she's talking about
Can they break it may break it may break
Oh wait, I need to click them
It's my hydrate
Oh boy
All right, does anybody need to take a quick break before uh, I'm ready. I'm ready. I'm ready. Okay
I'm ready. Let's do this
Oh
Okay, okay
Oh, that's really cute. I see what the hell
Oh my god
Okay
Yeah, I see what I see yet
Is it Arthur's hand?
Oh, that's so good
What do you mean you're a bad artist? That's a very good little bear. That's beautiful. Yeah, they're cute handwriting
He got a boner under the blanket and everything. Oh, yeah
Look at that
Oh, it's the Arthur rule. That's good now
Beautiful
I hope like what else could I draw for this? Oh, that's cute and wholesome with the fall
Okay, okay, okay
Uh
Oh
I saved them. I lied. I lied. I didn't save this meme at all
I was if I don't see a snail
Oh, that's pretty good, is there a
Oh my god
Oh my god guys on the same page that is I love replays. Oh my god
That's so cute
And then there's
Oh my god
No
No, it's cute. Yeah, that was cute
That's really cute
Oh
Me
Mine
He's so bad. I can't I can't show that
I see
We'll do it me and the boys that one. Oh, okay, okay
Oh
Why the mono bro?
Wait
Wait, I drew this little game. I was like, oh, this is like lane raider
Oh
And me
I told you I told you it was zara
Lama chubu for gentu
That's cute mercy
I see he's learning how to ride a bike, okay
Oh, that was good, that was a good one
That was good
Oh
Okay, hold on. I'll stop it. I'll cancel it. What are we doing?
Okay, yeah, it's boring. It's boring. Can I cancel it? I don't I can't uh, if you want, how do I cancel it? Okay, how do we cancel?
Oh
Wait, are we doing this? Oh, we're canceling it. I don't know
I cancel it. What is happening? Oh, there's a fucking ad
I'm just making another room. I'm making another room. Okay. Oh, okay. Okay
All right, where is my carry to that you guys can see john snow and sun's a star
Oh, wait, no, just put me back in
They still advertise
They put me in the same lobby and put me in this do you get one you guys want to get one of seven
But come on. What is happening? I don't know what is happening
Somebody else make a lobby. It's not the greatest but we can just play it. No. Well, somebody else make a lobby
Do we have a new lobby or not somebody else make it because I made a new one. I was trying to make a new one
Just threw me back in there. You should be timed out, right? Everyone hate the asset hate the game
The garlic phone window. Okay. Hide it first and then someone make a new one. I can't make it because my connections dog
I'll do it
See any proven what big girl she is
That was so fucking weird. I'm sorry
So fucking creepy. I'm so sorry. Thank god. We did all have to
Sorry, it's so it's so chaotic
I don't know why there's two of me on screen when I hate up
Get out take fun. Are we out of putting in your lobby here?
Uh, Amy just put up a new one. Amy's gonna shove us a link in the discord. You can hate
Okay, understood
Sorry, yes, sir
Let me open the link. Oh, there we go. Nice and easy
I
I'll go a patient
Okay, is everyone here?
I'm here. Yes. Um, I'm I'm here. Yeah, we're here. I'm in. Okay. Which one do you want to play?
Uh
Knock off is fun because it's like super
Try to replicate the dragon
Oh the drawing. Oh, yeah. Yeah, do knock off. Do knock off. That looks good. Okay
Because you make it pretty drawing and then it becomes hell. Oh, no, wait, why are we supposed to draw?
Anything you want, please
I am going to draw
Maybe not anything for you. No, no
Shit, please give us something. I'm being put on the spot. My main's going blank. Yeah, I don't know the draw. Let me
Let's do it. Oh, wait. Yeah, you're good. She maybe we can't see relax. I'll draw
I'm taking off the blindfold. You're fine now
I'll draw should be
Yeah, should we all just like draw somebody?
Oh
No, I'm joking. I'm joking. I'm joking
I was like, oh, I'm kind of locked in there. Uh, sorry. Sorry. I've decided to draw one of us
That I don't know what to draw
Guys, I mean I give me an idea
Don't put on the spot
Don't put me on the spot. I don't know. I don't even know what to draw
Put me on the G spot. I'm just, oh, one of you guys. So I'm gonna choose
On the spot
You want me to draw that?
Oh, this is terrible on a mouse
That one's actually funny
Uh, oh
Can I draw? How much time do we have? I'm like, can I draw the whole gang again?
You have quite a bit of time with this one
Okay, hold on. What the fuck is going to draw the whole gang with this? Oh, that that's not how berries look
How the fuck do you draw something sitting down? Oh my god, I'm having a stroke. I'm not the good kind
What on earth?
There's a good kind
Oh, very
I see after this
Oh my god, what I want to draw harmony. I want to draw you
Perfect I can't draw like this
Wait, it has kind of like
Who's next we need to draw the devilish
Fuck this is like I don't know what to fucking draw
Um
Get creative nerds. Jeez. It's not that
Okay, miss artist. Okay
Emmy comes out, Emmy's like, oh, I'm just gonna draw myself casually and it comes out with like this fucking banger of a commission
It would probably cost like 500 dollars to do
Um, she like bangs that out and I'm like, oh my god
He I'm gonna make a vtuber model. He
Wish I could wish I had a finger terrible talent
Speaking of that, so it's heavy a fucking marshmallow. They were like, thank you for not tying down your talents
To the designs that you assigned them and they can be more themselves. And I'm like, yeah, well, why would I do that?
I was like, I don't know why I feel like it's such a basic things. What the fuck do I need to draw now?
A bleeding heart
Yeah, we're just it's almost like we're more so like building upon
the characters rather than
changing everything
literally
because um
Oh someone rated the feature bridge
They were like the only thing that would have been it better is if you let them design their models like from the start
I'm like, bro. It took me a fucking year to get here. Like, oh my god. Give me
It takes forever to
Draw and rank a vtuber model. Yeah
You can ask him me. She knows how to she knows how to do it. It's a lot of work
Yeah, there's only a select few corpos that will let you do that
It literally takes so long. Oh, shit. Oh, shit. Oh, shit. This is wrong. Usually ones that have like artists in house as well
Yeah, we don't
Most companies if not all of them say first you will have pre
pre-made
Pre-made so it's not actually standard for people to choose. Yeah, it's really not. Yeah
That's why it's usually they cast for the roles
You have to fit the character they're looking for and have the voice
It's magic
You know
Oh
What is this?
Um, oh
Okay
Okay, now we have to draw it. Are we ready?
Yeah, um, no, but I guess I have to be
Even if I'm not it's okay
Just draw it your way and that's the fun part. Yeah, very nice
I've already forgot which position everyone
This is so bad
Sorry, we flinch honestly, I would talk more but this takes so much brain power. I'm literally I'm just like
I'm so brain dead like
I'm reading chat. I'm reading everything, but I'm not responding. I'm so sorry because the everyone see what you're all saying
I'm just really in this
I feel like I'm just fucking losing it
Oh my god, wait, I forgot I forgot there was a shorter time
That's far too short. So it's
This is why it's chaotic. Why was the other one longer? I don't remember what sugar. I didn't want to do that
Um
Oh my god, what
Oh, fuck the time
We draw this as fast as we can
Oh
Can't remember what it looked like
Is there supposed to be someone in a pirate boat by the way because I don't think I saw it
If there was supposed to be a person in it, I don't know. It's already they've already gone
There's a person
It's supposed to go really fast
Oh my god
Okay, that's that's easy enough
Okay, gotta go fast gotta go fast
Oh my god, I am so sorry
It's a little sun
Okay, okay, okay, we can do this we can do this
We can do this. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Don't panic. Don't panic
The great part is that we are all panicking
No, no, no, no
What even is that?
Okay, this is easy this is easy this has to be miss men's this has to be men's
Easy easy was a blue. I can't remember. Let's fucking go
Let's fucking go
Man this looks like shade but a while
Fuck
Have all the time I was like this is mr. Men
That's a little campfire
I gave him faces at the end of the day or all just
Okay, this is good this stage
The states
He's getting more and more the press somebody said
Oh, she's not in jail. She's at the cage
I
Just
Why she's shooting her piss
Oh
One more
Uh
All the actions are a mystery drawing and sentences are hitting during the game
What's secret secret seems rough. I've never done that one before
Okay, we'll try it. All right last round boys last round. Okay. Okay. Okay. Um
What I can't see what i'm writing. Oh secret. Oh sugar. I don't know what i'm writing. Wait, what?
Huh
Yeah, oh, no, wait you run out of freaking words. Oh, bro. I can't
I don't know
Um
It just appears. Oh, we can't see what we're drawing
Okay, we'll draw fast
Okay, I don't know I think
I'm gonna just guess
What it is where it is that's so fun
What the fuck
Oh, no, no
Uh, I'm gonna why is it so hard to draw with the mouse?
Oh, um, these are the past
Uh, I didn't give you his legs oh sugar
Yeah
Okay, see somewhere there get up. This is
Okay
Uh
I don't know what else to draw that's that's exactly what I drew I think
This is a vain reference. I don't know what the fuck i'm doing
Locked in
I locked in did I give wait
That's about that wrong. Wait, did I give them bodies? I don't think I gave them bodies. Oh my god
I don't even know where they are
I don't know
I'm taking a shot in the dark
Where so you know what that is going to be interpreted as
And will I stop the creative flow? Do you stop?
Wait, oh my god. Who's no emmy emmy's got a hoodie here. Oh sugar. I don't
Fuckin I put juice on her
I did my best
No, what the fuck i'm doing anymore. I'm fucking dying. What?
What is this? What is this?
What
Someone had to stroke whoever drew this one. Hope you're feeling okay. Hope you're doing all right. Make sure you hydrate
Fuck I didn't have enough time to write it
Uh, man, how do I even draw this?
This is uh
That's the tongue and then this is literally everyone
I don't know where the body is. This is the fuck am I drawing?
I need like motion swipes as well and a little arrow to indicate it's true. Yeah, I know what I'm doing. I don't know
And then yeah, there we go. I think I drew it correctly. A little bit of lipstick. Ah, where is it?
I can't wait to see the end of this. This is like great. This will be a great thing for the ages
What's going on the ceiling? Oh, I need to draw on the ceiling quick. Oh, I think I just
Oh god, I don't know. Oh boy. I'm so scared of what these look like
That's like two feet apart
Two feet apart
Oh
That's why you're a home in Indiana Jones. I was like
I was trying to write cowboy, but I
Did you draw in white?
And I used red as well and orange
I can't read. Oh my face hurt so bad. Oh
Oh
The fucking eraser that's why you're going to fucking see you
How do we get back to boobs?
Well, actually that potato was really bad never mind
Oh
Oh my god, this is amazing. That's how we got there. Oh, they drew us
Your mom calling me that night
Oh
My cheeks hurt from
Can somebody download that one I'm down
I
Tag yourself. I'm the ropes
I'm tying emmy to the tracks
Oh my god
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna endure the girls to anything more because like we're our faces are ready to fall off after that
Is anyone doing a stream
Is anyone are you doing a stream right away is narrow because I'll do something really bad, right? I'm gonna jump out of the call
If I'm going to jump out of the call
I
I'm going to jump out of the call and do a little that so then I'll redirect into you as a role, okay
Okay, I might play do you guys want me I might play some call the lamb so
If you if someone does a pop-up stream, just tell me I'll talk to that my refunds for a bit
Thank you so so much all members and dolls for this hilarity that ensued after such an amazing start
Such a wonderful start to power wash chat myself from laughing so hard. So thanks
We already know Icy's panties are soaked. So
Oh
All right, let me sniff let me sniff test
Right, I'm gonna jump out of chat. Thank you so much
We'll be doing collabs next week with each other. So look out for that
Uh, and I'll jump out of chat. Thank you so much. Uh, my darlings my daughters my girls
I'll talk to you very shortly. Okay. I'm off to the refunds. I love you my daughters
Kisses from all of the lure girls, holy crap
Yeah
They're so cute, right, you know, you're still in call
Oh
That was really something
Okay, wait, I'm so are you guys still streaming? Yeah. Oh, I am. Yeah. I don't I don't know what to do
If you like I lost my ability to stream
Okay, let's go off go to just add in the right into into azra
I think azra's next right
I'll see
Me and azra are gonna be streaming. She's doing stardew. I'm doing call the lamb
Um
So she be and azra are going to stream right now. Yeah, I'm gonna keep streaming
No
No, I'm gonna I'm probably gonna I'm probably gonna end this one so that the bot is separated. Oh, yeah, that's a good idea
Actually, I'll end it make a new one
Okay
Hang up and then I'll go to the uh, la la la just chatting and then I'll send I'll I'll check if y'all ready. Okay later
Hey, okay. Bye. Bye
Oh, that was fun that was that was a fucking ball
And like I'm not gonna lie. This is literally what our discord is
Oh, such a fun time. I hope you guys enjoyed. Um, I'm gonna see if anybody, uh, donated real quick
Let me not just like pull up my stream elements
Um
And say thank you. Oh my god. I'm lily and tears my mouth and my jaw hurt
Oh
I'd say let's say thank you for the $10 tip from anonymous and thank you to boy
For the $1 tip six vods sure at least one of them stays up. I'm keeping mine up. You can't put me down
All right, I don't know why I was selling like Jamaican. Um
But yeah, I'm gonna end stream and then I'm gonna start another one. I really got a fucking poop. Um
Oh my lord
Oh my god, it was it was so frustrating because we were all trying to get power washed into the work
but yeah, like as strani said when um
when there was like
if we tried to add, uh
All six of us if there was like five or four of us we could make it work
But like six like it just it kept crashing like not even like it just wouldn't connect. I don't know if it's because
Um where strani is we couldn't connect properly because she was hosting
Uh
I was like we were so bummed so I'm like, don't worry
They're like, do we need to end it today? I'm like, no, we don't need to
postpone it
We'll just play something else. And so I ran through like some things. I'm like, okay, gary's mod we can play hide and seek
Or prop one. They're like none of us have it. I'm like, okay. Uh, what about if we do this? They're like, okay
We don't have that. I'm like
Okay, what if you guys get this? Okay. What about jack box because you guys also said jack box and then we realize
Oh, but you would you would all kind of have to be watching my stream
And I'm like, I don't want to take the entire viewership of this collab
um
because and it would be kind of
Uh, I don't even think it would be possible for us to stream our
respective
um
Windows properly because you have to like answer everything from a phone anyway
So it doesn't it wouldn't really work out but we might try to work out the kinks of that another time perhaps. I don't know
um
I feel like that's a good like
Uh stream with like, uh, you guys because it's a little bit easier because you guys all look at your own phone or whatever
um, and then
Yeah, it all ended well because I was like, oh wait, what's that freaking
Pictionary like game
And I was like isn't there like garter phone. I'm like, okay perfect. I've never played guard like I've never played garter phone before
um, but
like
I will always I just noticed strani is a piece of pizza. Uh, I will always
Like because I could tell strani was getting stressed. I'm like, don't worry. We'll be fine. We got this
Um, we don't have to postpone it. We don't have to just like we don't have to cancel anything
I was gonna I what I wanted to do
I wanted to do like csgo commentator
Of like them playing power wash like really badly and just like not be in it
Like so you guys wouldn't have like I was just would have still streamed
What you guys wouldn't have gotten my viewpoint. Uh, I would probably just like
react stream to like strani's uh, or like emmy's thing. Um
The northerline crew do jackbox a lot. Yeah, so I'm like, I know it's possible
But we just don't we'll probably break up the kinks for that. Um
But yeah, everything worked out fine. I'm glad we had lots of fun time
I always love hanging out with them. I also just like didn't want to postpone hanging out though
Because we hadn't um, like we'll talk all the time in like chat, but we haven't like, um, played a game together in a bit
So I was like, oh no, I want to I want to hang out with my girls
Oh, like anything happened
Yeah, what honestly you would have you would have liked what strani had um set up for
Power wash because we were gonna do like a little q&a and like the little skit where we're trying to like make money
Because nobody watches us or whatever. So we just resort to power washing. Um, but yeah, we're we are
Like I think we all have really good chemistry
As a group we're all just so goofy together and I I just love it so much like I wouldn't I wouldn't ask for
any other group of hilarious freaking girls because
Like we all like some of us will surprise each other like the freakiest shit like just like like evi today like just
doing the most
silly drawings
In like
It's just fun
We need to get I see more hobbies than piss in older men
Yeah, because it's like we all have our little like jokes that we stick to um
Which is but like also like toilet humor is funny like I'm sorry it kind of is that in slapstick humor
But we can't exactly do slapstick online
Um, unless it's like maybe like a 3d thing
Excuse me
um and
But yeah, like we're definitely never gonna beat the pp poo poo corp allegations
But yeah, I hope you guys enjoyed uh, I'm gonna end I'm gonna come back and like
15 minutes, so I'll come back at 4 15 and I'll start um, let's see if we can
Beat the silk song
Not silk song. I'm thinking of fucking hollow night the silk
uh area
For our uh call the lamb
I'm gonna throw on some uh crowd control so you guys can fuck around
Um next week I'm planning on doing inscription with crowd control. So I'm very excited for that
You got a lot of fun some stuff
fun stuff
Set up for next uh next week and a lot of I have a couple collapse
um
I we're gonna I'm gonna do a collab with tomah keys my sweet little monkey gal
um with her character trinket who's like this valley girl character and we're gonna be doing smash or pass of um
Pokemon and it's really funny because uh, she's drawing trinket in like a like a harem
Outfit like she's like what do you she's like, what do your hair members usually wear? I'm like, I don't know
slutty
business attire
It's like do like some slave lay of shit. She's like perfect. Um, and then uh, I have an asmr
Then if you have like inscription
um, then I have an overcooked collab with uh chai chan and um
uh noriko
We've played that together before and it was so funny. So I know you guys will enjoy
um
And yeah, I'll probably try to I was
I have I don't yeah, I have a collab with azura. I think we're playing fall guys
Um with the viewers so that'll be really awesome. So it'd be packed with collabs
I know some people don't like collabs because it kind of limits chat interaction, but I hope with like fall guys and stuff
Um, it'll be really really funny. Um
And I was supposed to
Um stream on sunday because I was supposed to be another collab with the girls
But I'm not going to be able to make that because I'm I'm going back to work and there's they want to do it at a time
I can't do it and it really bums me out because I want to spend time with them
um
When it's just me and strab strawny because we're just fucking yapping to our
Our chats probably and haven't turned off stream. Um
But yeah next week will be fun. Oh, and it's just me left
Um, but yeah, I hope you guys
I will enjoy and I'll see you in like 15 minutes. Bye